Walt Guy's biography is on the website.
I hope you've had a chance to look at it.
I will just say briefly that I guess, of all
the lecturers coming, that Walt is the only
one who is still actually working actively
for NASA.
He is head of the Automation, Robotics and
Simulation Division, division chief at the
Johnson Space Center.
But that is not what he's talking about there.
He's talking about the job that he used to
do for about 20 years which was head of environmental
thermal life support and crew systems.
And, of course, the crew system includes all
the space suits and the good stuff that I
was fortunate enough to get to use.
So I've got a personal debt of thanks to Walt.
Aaron, I think you wanted to say a couple
of things so I will pass the microphone to
you.
Yes, I would like to say a few words about
Walt.
We've worked together for many years.
And Walt Guy has the very unique capability
of being not only an outstanding engineer,
a technical person, but he also has a very
unique capability of being a great or outstanding
project manager, program manager.
No matter what task you gave Walt, he could
deliver the product on performance, on schedule
and on time.
He has that unique capability.
And he's done that from the Apollo Program
through the Shuttle Program.
And I think you're really in for a treat to
hear Walt talk about the environmental control
systems.
He has a lot of information to offer you so,
without further ado, let me turn it over to
Walt.
Thank you, Aaron.
As Aaron said, we worked together over several
programs over a long period of time.
I was noticing the picture.
I'm sure that wasn't put there for me.
But my current responsibilities are the robotic
arm you see there.
That is a shuttle arm.
Of course there are station arms also.
Grapple fixture over here on the left.
And the little jet pack on the tumbling crewman
there is part of my current responsibilities.
The 20 years that Jeff mentioned, I was responsible
for the development of the Shuttle spacesuit.
So it was like it was meant for me anyway.
What I'd like to do is talk about the design.
I know in the syllabus it said environmental
control systems.
So where did all the rest of the stuff come
from?
If you go back in perspective, the Mercury,
Gemini, Apollo Program had the classical thing
that aerospace calls environmental control
systems.
It was basically a cabin system.
It took care of the living quarters for the
crew.
But in the Shuttle era the responsibility
of that system expanded to include more than
just the cabin and, thus, the very long hard
to say name.
These are the subsystem elements of the environmental
thermal control and life support system.
The first area I am going to -- These are
the areas, the subsystems.
The first area is the cabin atmospheric revitalization
system.
This is a long way of saying to take care
of the atmosphere in the cabin.
Humans are pollutants and this is the system
that takes care of that.
The cabin atmospheric pressure and composition,
this is obviously to maintain the pressure
and enough oxygen for breathing.
The third is the cabin thermal control, and
that is the classical environmental control
system.
But, for Shuttle, we've added some functions.
One is the water and waste management subsystem.
There are some hygiene functions required,
there are some recharge of the spacesuit's
backpack, management of the fuel cell water
system, the fuel cells of the electrical power
supply and provide a lot of extra water.
Also, the vehicle at this point, has a dedicated
active thermal control system that takes care
of all of the systems in the vehicle, not
just the cabin systems.
And then last is the airlock support subsystem.
This is the EVA crewman's portal to space.
And so the environmental thermal control and
life support system covers all these areas.
What I will do is go through each one of those.
The first is the cabin atmospheric revitalization
system.
Its functions are CO2 and trace gas removal,
humidity control, environmental cooling and
atmospheric circulation and ventilation.
Again, I will talk each about these.
But I do want to mention that there is a uniqueness
about space and that there is no convection
so circulation is important.
Also, because of the fact that there is no
convection, getting rid of the body heat,
the latent heat requires a ventilation of
the crew.
So each of these areas ended up as part of
the system design.
This is an overview silhouette of the Orbiter.
I will use this throughout the presentation.
As you can see, part of the system we're talking
about now, the atmospheric revitalization
system is located upfront where the crew is.
It is beneath the floor.
And we will be talking about the systems in
the remainder of the Orbiter as we go along.
This is a simplified schematic.
I would like to start at the cabin fans.
These are redundant.
Each fan will do the job.
The next in line is the CO2 scrubber followed
by the cooler, the cabin heat exchanger.
There is a bypass around that for control
of the amount of cooling that is needed.
As you are aware, the Shuttle can fly with
few or many crewmen.
It turns out, as time has gone on, we fly
pretty much a full compliment.
But the original design was to fly a small
number of crewmen.
Also, this does give you temperature control.
The same heat exchanger provides the condensation
of the water from the atmosphere.
Therefore, you get humidity control.
And then that is collected.
The gas continues on.
It is now chilled and is provided out to the
flight deck and the middeck to the crew.
Then the gas from the cabin is then drawn
back in through some flight deck avionics
and back through the fans.
So this is the basic systems schematic.
I might pause here a moment to sort of explain
the role of the government in the development
of the Shuttle.
As you know, the prime was Rockwell.
It was their job to build the vehicle.
But the government philosophy, management
philosophy was to have ownership of the technical
aspects of the design.
So we had basically no excuse.
If it didn't work it wasn't because the contractor
did something wrong.
We had to have ownership.
In fact, Aaron, as the project manager, would
probably look to us first as the reason for
a problem as opposed to Rockwell because we
were the conscience of the program so we should
have made sure they didn't do it wrong and
provided whatever technical insight to Aaron
to make sure he made the programmatic decisions
to make sure things were not done wrong.
Very early in the Shuttle Program, I was responsible
for an engineering organization.
And that engineering organization wanted to
own the design of the environmental thermal
control and life support system.
We acquired a chamber.
This is a near atmospheric chamber.
It is a square so it is obviously not shaped
like the Orbiter cabin, but the volume was
appropriate.
And it did allow a sealed environment for
testing.
It would take a couple of PSI delta Ps.
That's about all it would take.
We developed a -- [COMMENT FROM HOFFMAN],
No, that was a different one.
OK.
We developed an environmental control system
or an atmospheric revitalization control system
and placed it inside to do early testing.
As you can see here, this is the fan package.
The CO2 scrubbers are here.
Heat exchange package over here.
And you can tell we're not current in terms
of calendar-wise.
The CO2 and trace gas removal, the requirements
were to maintain less than 7.6 millimeters
of mercury.
This is certainly to provide a habitable environment
for the crew.
This is higher than sea level but the medics
agreed that that was a completely adequate
level for CO2.
The CO2 absorption came from the humidified
cabin gas so the system had to accommodate
that as a feed stream.
The absorbent selected was lithium hydroxide.
The equation was a lithium hydroxide reacted
with the CO2 to produce lithium carbonate,
water and heat.
And this was a single use system.
It turns out that the lithium hydroxide was
an old solution.
The previous spacecraft had used the same
solution, but pretty much their solution was
unique purchased production of lithium hydroxide.
When we entered the Shuttle era, we were hoping
for a long duration.
And the idea was to use the commercial products
to get away from special production.
And so we looked around.
And the Navy was producing a screened special
production run for their submarines.
So there was a lot of use there.
And so the production was reasonably upo.
We decided to use the Navy grade.
And so we brought it in and put it in the
test bed that I just showed you and did some
tests, and it didn't work worth a darn.
You notice the loops here show that our use
of the canister was much more rapid that we
had hoped for.
The nice beautiful deep loops here are a process
that we developed to screen the Navy LiOH
so that we didn't have to create a new production
capability but were able to test the LiOH
that came off their production line and get
a LiOH that was much more humidity tolerant.
The key here turned out to be not the chemical
itself but its ability to produce good performance
over a wide humidity range.
So we were able to screen that and make that
a viable non-special production run LiOH.
The lithium hydroxide, I said, was an old
solution.
All previous spacecraft have been pretty short
mission.
And even the Shuttle was a short mission.
But the specification for Shuttle said that
it should have a capability of going 28 days,
and 28 days is not a short mission, at least
not in Shuttle parlance.
The engineering part of the organization said,
well, why don't we go with a regenerative
system?
SkyLab had just been successfully flown with
a regenerative system, something that wouldn't
have all this expendables because 28 days
worth of lithium hydroxide for seven crewmen
fills everything up with lithium hydroxide.
There is no room for anything else.
So we began to look at a regenerative system
that could be used.
Actually, it was proposed as part of the original
Shuttle development.
But, at that point, the 28-day mission was
considered a special case and the design case
was the shorter missions.
And, in fact, there were even projected to
be a lot of short missions.
The idea that the Shuttle was a space truck.
It would take stuff up, dump it out and come
home.
And so the lithium hydroxide was a lighter
system than a regenerative system.
The lithium hydroxide was placed into the
vehicle as a basic design.
But, when the Space Lab era came along, we
needed longer missions.
We flew about four or five times in this 13
to 16 day range, and those missions did require
a lot of lithium hydroxide.
And so it was proposed to use an absorbent
that was regenerable, and the one that was
selected was a solid amine.
The absorbent is a polymerized ethyleneimine.
Its designation is RNH, and I don't really
know why.
The absorption actually comes in, in two steps.
First there is a reaction with water to create
the Freon.
And then that is then reactive with the CO2
to give you another free ion, but the CO2
is now captured.
The desorption then with the heat and vacuum
gives you back your original amine.
So if you pack this in a bed, and what we
used was an expanded metal foam heat exchanger
that you could fill all the holes with the
solid amine and put the passages adjacent
to each other so that you could use the heat
of absorption to do your desorption on your
other side.
And all you would need to do is expose it
to vacuum.
It was a very simple system.
It worked fine for the three or four missions.
I'm not sure how many missions it was used.
But it was an adjunct.
It was added in, put onto the floor, and then
it was taken back out when it was no longer
needed because it was just wasted load.
Yes.
For the lithium hydroxide, the product LiCO3,
is that a solid form or a gas form?
No, it's a solid lithium carbonate.
And that goes in the canisters that you remove?
Right.
When you remove the canister it's a big lump.
OK.
Finishing up the CO2 and trace removal, we
go to the trace removal and use the simple
system of activated charcoal.
And, in fact, it is packed into the same canister
that the lithium hydroxide is packed into.
It is a single use.
There is a configuration, I believe, now operationally
where the entire canister is activated charcoal
so it can be used for cabin gas cleanup.
So, if you had an issue that you needed to
clean the cabin up, you could do that with
a canister just of charcoal.
The next area is the environmental cooling
and humidity control.
I mentioned on the schematic that we have
a cabin heat exchanger.
The front part of the heat exchanger basically
is your reduced cabin gas temperature.
The backend of the heat exchanger is where
the condensing occurs because we get the gas
below the dew point and, therefore, the water
drops out.
The heat exchanger has the characteristic
that, as the water collects at the outlet
of the heat exchanger, there were some holes
drilled, actually, in the thin passages so
the water can be sucked out.
And it has the nickname "slurper." So it slurps
the water out.
It takes about 2% of the flow.
So, as the cabin fan produces the flow through
the heat exchanger, about 2% is siphoned off
in the slurper.
And that carries the water to the centripetal
water gas separator.
This is a device that basically spins the
airstream.
It's an airstream with water and trained.
It spins the airstream.
The water goes to the outside.
It is collected in a trough and there is a
pitot tube in the trough that the water impinges
on, and we get about a 40 PSI delta head with
that.
It's just a pump basically, a pitot pump.
The atmospheric circulation and ventilation
is the next part of the system.
As you know, we're still in atmospheric revitalization.
There are the redundant fans that I mentioned.
Each fan will do the job.
There is also flight deck and mid deck duct
system.
It looks very complicated but there are only
several points I want to make here.
This is the atmospheric revitalization system
I mentioned before.
As you see, it is below the floor.
This is the mid deck here.
This is the flight deck.
So it's below the floor of the mid deck.
The gas exits the heat exchanger.
It goes up.
There is some aft mid deck ventilation exhaust.
It goes on up to the flight deck and exhausts
on the flight deck.
Also there is a section that goes on the forward
side of the cabin through the forward control
console and blows in the face of the crew.
The return is back through some avionic areas
to provide cooling, and then back down to
the system.
This is a complicated picture, but really
it is a very simple flow system.
This becomes important later in our discussion
because good mixing turned out to be a really
important parameter.
Not just cooling.
OK.
The second.
Remember we had six?
This is the second element.
This is the atmospheric pressure and composition
control.
The first job is the 14.7.
The Shuttle selected sea level, the idea being
we could not have a lot of special designed
equipment.
Shuttle was intended to be a less expensive
spacecraft than the previous ones.
And so a sea level atmosphere gave us no questions
about human survival and gave us a lot of
opportunity for using more standard equipment
and not specially designed equipment.
There was a requirement, though, for a PSIA
total control, but this was only for an emergency
de-orbit.
The problem statement is that you got a hole
in your cabin.
Don't know how you got it but you have it.
And the idea is the system has to be able
to sustain the crew for a de-orbit.
And I don't know who made up the number but
169 minutes is the number.
We have an emergency return, 169 minutes.
The system has to be able to accommodate that
keeping the total pressure at or above 8 PSI.
So there has to be enough flow capability,
enough consumables to do that.
The half-inch hole was a programmatic decision.
I cannot speak for where the number exactly
came from, but it probably had to do with
meteoroid debris kind of analysis that said
what type of hole you could expect.
Anyway, that was the design for the system.
The next aspect or element of the system is
the O2/N2 partial pressure control.
At the total pressure of 14.7, we wanted sea
level which is about 3.2 PSI oxygen.
At the 8 PSI, we wanted it to be survivable
but the oxygen could be less.
Obviously, people live in Denver so that works.
There are also crew breathing masks which
can be used in conjunction with low oxygen
partial pressure.
The cabin had to have both positive and negative
relief.
It had to store the oxygen and nitrogen, and
it had to provide pressurization for the water
management system.
Remember earlier I talked about the more pervasive
requirements?
The water and waste management system now
is placing requirements on the atmospheric
pressure and composition control.
This is a silhouette again where basically
here you see the oxygen tank, which is 3300
PSI oxygen tank.
There are nitrogen tanks on both sides.
These are high pressure tanks all 3300 PSI.
The relief valves are shown here.
And there is an O2/N2 supply panel which has
all of the valves and regulators and everything
on it.
This system, however, though, gets most of
its oxygen from the cryogenic tanks.
So that is only just shown as an inlet.
These tanks are basically part of the power
control system.
Electrical power is hydrogen and oxygen fuel
cell.
We use a lot less oxygen than they do so the
storage was integrated.
And then we use the oxygen for most of the
uses.
It comes from the main tanks.
This is a schematic.
I will start right there.
This is the cryogenic system.
This is the main cryogenic system.
This is not part of the tankage of the pressure
and composition control system.
It goes through a restrictor.
This is stored in a super critical state so
the delivery is somewhat limited.
And so this goes through a restrictor so that
we don't decrease the pressure too fast in
the cryogenic tank.
It comes on down through a regulator that
regulates down to 100 PSI.
And that comes on down to two regulators.
One is the normal regulator, the 14.7, and
the other is the 8 PSI regulator, both of
which are available depending on which cabin
mode you're in.
If you go over this way you will see the nitrogen.
The nitrogen goes through its own regulator,
and it is regulated at 200 PSI.
And that's important because that is contrasted
to the 100 here.
Next the nitrogen goes through an on/off valve,
a solenoid that is connected to partial pressure
sensors of oxygen.
And, if you're making up cabin gas, you have
to make a choice as to whether you want nitrogen
or oxygen.
And that choice is made by this system and
a simple on/off valve.
There is no sophisticated control system.
This is a simple on/off valve.
If the cabin needs pressure but doesn't need
oxygen then this valve is open and the 200
PSI basically backs down the oxygen system.
There is a check valve here, no oxygen flow
because you get nitrogen.
At the point that you need oxygen, this valve
closes, then there is no 200 PSI anymore.
Therefore, the 100 PSI provides oxygen to
the regulators.
It is a very simple design.
Off the top of your head, what kind of failures
did you have during qual test that really
bothered you?
The regulators were produced by Carlton, and
the regulators were derivatives of regulators
they had been building for years.
So the regulator functions really were pretty
good.
But the early problem we had was the pressure
tolerance wandered and didn't have as good
a pressure tolerance.
And they did make some mods to correct that.
But the more significant issues got into flow
issues.
Their test capability was pretty limited.
And when you're talking about very high flow
cases you have to do something with the gas
to make the regulator think that it is in
an operational environment.
And so we did a lot of testing, and I will
show you that in just a second, for the high
flow cases.
Let's see.
There is a redundant system.
It is not shown in this schematic but there
are two of these, just like this.
This is the pressurization for the water and
waste management system you see here.
I would say there is a crossover to the redundant
system so that you can do mix and match.
If you have a problem in both systems, you
can mix and match the capabilities.
Also, the oxygen system provides the emergency
breathing system.
It also provides oxygen to the air lock for
recharge of the backpack.
We will talk about that later.
And I believe that's it.
So, for normal pressure, we have 14.7.
And you have the automatic pressure regulator,
basically on/off valve and the regulator.
The partial pressure is controlled by the
3.2 PSI which is the solenoid that controls
that.
It is a very simple system.
The oxygen partial pressure does have another
set point at the PSIA goes down to 2.45 PSI.
And I will show you that in a minute.
For cabin pressure relief, the problem statement
really is why do you need relief?
Well, what if one of those lines breaks?
You've got 3300 PSI tankage.
It is all plumed together.
The crew, God forbid, step on a line and break
it, and now you've got all this nitrogen rushing
in.
You don't want the cabin to explode, right?
So you need a relief valve.
And the relief valve was set at 16.2.
And, again, that is one of the high flow cases
that we ended up testing.
The system was designed with three relief
valves.
Any tool will do the job.
That is just a redundancy philosophy.
Sometimes you will see two items where either
one does the job.
In this case, this is a very critical issue
so there is a double redundancy here.
For the negative pressure protection, there
is an 8 PSI delta relief valve.
In fact, there are three of those.
You don't need the two to operate, but there
are three.
This is for the return that I just showed
you.
If you come back with a hole in the cabin,
the cabin is at 8 PSI, you cannot reverse
flow through that hole.
That is not going to work.
You don't want the cabin imploding on the
crew so you've got to make up, as you come
in the lower altitude, obviously the higher
pressure, you've got to get that gas back
in the cabin.
So that's what that is for.
OK.
This is the other pressure vessel that was
used as a test site.
This was called the Environmental Test Article.
Rockwell gave it that name.
What they planned to do with this device,
when they built it, was to do all the wiring
runs and the plumbing runs in there.
It was going to be a mockup.
It turned out they built a rather beefy tank.
In fact, maybe they got one very inexpensively.
I'm not sure how they ended up with it, but
they got it.
They did do all the secondary structure, so
it had the right shape inside.
And so it turned out they didn't end up using
it.
They went onto other methods.
And so it ended up leftover in the program.
We convinced Aaron that he ought to give it
to us, and he did.
This is what it looks like in cutaway.
You see here all the secondary structure,
it was in boxes but we put it all in.
Foamed it in so that the volume was right,
so the cabin volume was essentially perfect.
It had the flight deck.
It had the mid deck.
It had the lower deck for the environmental
control system.
But we also asked Aaron to give us the cert
hardware, which he did.
So we had the cert hardware underneath the
floor.
And the pressure control system we're talking
about, actually, is on this back wall.
That is a picture of it.
What we did is faithfully run the lines.
In fact, we even use the same line material,
same fittings, same everything.
So we faithfully duplicated inside this test
article the volume and the geometry and the
system.
All the ventilation ducts you saw, all those
were in place.
We will come back to it later, but you'll
notice on the back wall of this test facility
there is an airlock hatch.
And later on I will tell you where that goes.
But this is the control panel and the nitrogen/oxygen
system.
This is test data.
We did some testing to see how the system
worked.
This was testing of basically the on/off oxygen
control system.
Let me see if I can walk through this simply.
We're working total pressure here, oxygen
partial pressure here.
During this first interval the oxygen is on.
What we're doing here is we're breathing it
down.
And, when we hit the lower limit so that the
regulator wants to do something, then the
oxygen partial pressure starts up because
the regulator comes on.
Now, the total pressure is maintained because
that is what the regulator is supposed to
do, maintain total pressure.
But as it maintains the total pressure it
is doing it with oxygen and, therefore, the
partial pressure is going up.
When it is satisfied, that is enough partial
pressure of oxygen, then the solenoid valve
opens and you see the nitrogen come on.
Now, you remember the nitrogen feed was at
300 PSI versus 200 PSI.
So there is a little jump.
That is just a mechanical artifact of the
regulator.
If you change the inlet pressure it regulates
slightly differently because it is a balance
system.
You see a little jump there.
And then, during this period, the pressure
is maintained.
But we're breathing off the oxygen because
we've got the oxygen fenced off now.
And then when the pressure is satisfied and
the solenoid goes back the other way then
we again start the oxygen again.
So the system worked quite well.
If you notice the tolerance band spec-wise
was pretty wide, the system operated on a
very narrow brand so we were very pleased
with that.
Normally that is important.
Not only because it shows you that you do
have a good sensitive system, but you cannot
-- Mechanical hardware, electrical hardware,
either one never operates down the middle
always.
There is drift.
You need a little tolerance in your band here
to have a decent system design.
Yes.
Does this change a lot when you have the crew
performing high metabolic activity?
The cabin is so large that it really doesn't
know.
The cycles would be different, obviously,
because you consume more oxygen, you would
need more oxygen.
So the on/off cycle would favor longer oxygen
cycles.
But, in the big picture, there is really not
a lot of change.
What was this time period?
It looks like this was about three hours maybe.
That might go to two hours for a cycle.
I mean not really very much.
Sorry.
Does microgravity have much effect on circulation?
There is no circulation in microgravity.
It just lays there.
You push it or it doesn't go.
Diffusion is a driving force, so if you're
really, really patient, even at zero G you
can wait, but you cannot stay alive that way.
But, yes, you do have to have ventilation.
Still in the atmospheric pressure and composition
control.
This is the emergency breathing equipment.
We used plug-in face masks.
There are some uses for the mask that require
a carry on bottle to give portability, but
the vehicle does have plug-in capability.
The masks were purge-type masks.
You're probably not familiar much with masks,
but there is a mask called a rebreather which
basically your lung power does all the work
and you only purge enough to keep the CO2
down and you keep rebreathing.
And then the purge-type is every breath is
a fresh breath, and you then exhale and the
gas goes out in the cabin.
And that's the type that this is because the
cabin needs the oxygen.
I mean it's not going anywhere bad.
It is OK that it's not completely spent.
It's good.
That's like a scuba mask, right?
I don't scuba.
Sorry.
But I think the answer is yes.
With scuba, you take in the air and then you
blow it all out.
I mean there are scuba rebreathing systems,
but the typical scuba gear is not.
Rather than raising your hand, if you make
a noise of some kind.
Sorry.
I don't mean to ignore you.
The mask can be used in a contaminated environment
and the mask can be used if the concentration
of O2 is low to give you a better oxygen level.
This is the PSIA test that we did.
Actually, a series of tests.
But this is data from one.
As you see, we started up in the 14.7 range.
We simulated the hole.
The pressure immediately starts down.
The partial pressure of oxygen we let degrade
to about the 2.2 range.
This is a different set point.
Remember I told you on the oxygen sensors
we have two set points?
This is the second set point.
And so we have the lower oxygen partial pressure.
The system came down.
The PSIA regulator, which is always online,
captured the pressure decay, caught it, and
the solenoid valve popped back and forth to
keep the oxygen OK because we're losing now.
We're going out this half-inch hole.
And the system worked just fine.
This did have the crew on the masks because
that is livable, you can live there, but the
mask is a better environment.
This is a mask case.
This was a requirement that came on later.
The design is the design now.
The vehicle exists so we have to now operate
the vehicle with accommodations for operationally
what we want to do with it.
And a new requirement developed and was imposed
on the vehicle.
And that requirement had to do with the space
suit for the EVA operation.
The Shuttle spacesuits are basically 100%
O2.
And the classical way of going EVA from a
sea level environment was a four hour prebreathe.
Actually, as much as six hours depending on
how conservative the medics were at the time,
that number varied around some, to prevent
bends.
But it was determined that if you accommodized
at 9 PSI for about 12 hours then you only
required a really short prebreathe.
And the suit-up time, which gave you 30 to
40 minutes, actually gave you sort of a free
tune-up to your prebreathe as part of your
suit-up operation.
And so that was viewed as a much better way
to do EVAs than the previous way.
The masks are useful but are not very comfortable.
So, if you have to keep them on for a long
period of time, they're not very comfortable
at all.
Also the medics were very concerned about
mask leakage, that if there was any nitrogen
inflow that that could break the prebreathe.
But our system isn't designed for 9.
We have a 14.7 and an eight, but we don't
have a 9, so we needed a manual procedure.
But before that could be accepted there were
some issues that had to be evaluated.
And we had to do testing on each of these
issues.
The first is the flow rate acceptability at
9 PSI.
Obviously, the less dense gas you're not going
to get the same mask flow rate.
And we had to make sure that that ventilation
was going to be adequate.
And testing proved that it was.
The next is a thermal acceptability.
There are really two aspects to this.
One is the fan itself is cooled by the environment,
so if the environment doesn't provide as much
cooling to fan itself it could overheat.
Also, the electronic equipment, some of which
is air cooled, the less dense gas could be
a problem there.
It turned out that could be controlled with
load control.
That could off load power and make that acceptable.
The CO2 performance at 9 PSI, we needed to
make sure that was OK.
It turned out that, of course, the 9 PSI case,
we don't care about the lithium hydroxide.
The purge flow is so great there is no CO2
problem.
But at 9 PSI for 12 hours you have to get
performance out of the lithium hydroxide.
So we checked that and that worked out fine.
And the last item was the ventilation adequacy.
We do have a press and depress.
You've got to come down to 9 and you've got
to go back.
And both of those adjust the gas mixture.
And so we wanted to prove that that was OK.
And so we went to the facility that we were
talking about and ran this profile.
Now, this profile was created by our-- yes?
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
Well, that's what I just said.
Yes, it does.
The air-cooled equipment is going to run hot.
If you want to cool that equipment, it will
become a little clearer later, but the equipment
is in equipment bays.
And so, with the less dense gas, you need
to have some of that equipment turned off
so that the cooling that is available is adequate.
So you do load control, get rid of some of
the electronics.
And, therefore, the air that's left, the atmosphere
that is left can cool the equipment.
And then when do you increase the pressure
back to normal after the EVA?
After the 12 hours.
No, actually it's before the EVA.
Well, I'm not sure what they do now.
When you're all finished with your EVAs then
you bring the cabin back.
Because, typically, you do multiple EVAs.
And so, from one day to the next, you just
keep the cabin at, actually, we use 10.2 now
rather than 9, but I think you have to certify
it for 9, right?
This was an early certification for 9.
Yes.
But wouldn't it have been easier to simply
design the whole system for 9 from the beginning
if you had [OVERLAPPING VOICES]?
Well, this was not a Shuttle requirement.
This was an operational requirement that occurred
after the Shuttle specifications were set.
You're correct.
If we knew it ahead of time it would have
been much easier to do it all for 9 PSIs,
exactly.
It would have just been a third condition.
But, as Jeff pointed out, we changed our mind.
The first was 9 and now we're at 10.2, so
we're not consistent.
As we learn, we change our mind.
And the 10.2 was selected later.
Our mission operations people that do the
crew time lining and all, they created this
procedure.
And so we tested it.
This has a simple depress cycle.
You come from 14.7.
You hesitate at about 11 and replenish the
oxygen.
You do that twice.
You then do manual control down at the 9 psi
level.
You notice the oxygen partial pressure here
is always maintained by these adjustments,
and also during the manual period you select
what you want.
And then when you come back, the procedure
was to increase the nitrogen and then finish
the top off with oxygen.
That was thought to be completely acceptable
because the oxygen level, at this point, is
completely viable.
And so doing the nitrogen first and topping
it off with oxygen was thought to be an acceptable
way to operate.
So we did the test and this is what happened.
We were all nice and comfortable with our
oxygen partial pressure.
And you see the area next to where we were
repressing.
We depleted the oxygen substantially.
And the mid deck and even the flight deck,
we depleted the oxygen.
And I've only shown you half the data.
If you look at the rest of the data, you see
where the oxygen went.
These equipment bays that I mentioned earlier,
the avionics bays and other equipment bays
are basically isolated volumes from the cabin.
So, as the pressure comes up, what you're
doing is you're pressurizing these areas with
cabin gas, which is oxygen and nitrogen, you're
pressurizing these areas with nitrogen only.
Basically, you are depleting the partial pressure
here.
You're increasing the partial pressure here.
You remember partial pressure.
You just count the molecules.
That's all you have to do.
Basically, we're putting more oxygen molecules
here and we're taking them out of these areas.
And, therefore, they are going down.
This is just a picture of one of the bays.
You see all the empty space around the equipment.
That is where the gas is.
We came up with an alternate procedure which
is to simultaneously put the oxygen and nitrogen
in together.
And, of course, there is the 9 back to 14.7.
And you notice that solved the problem.
There is still some dip at the supply area
because the mixture is lean.
We need from 9 to 14.7, 5.7 PSI total pressure
increase.
But we only need 2.5 up to 3.2 oxygen.
This is a mixture, but it's a lean mixture.
So there is still some slight loss, but the
only area that came under an issue is near
the inlet where the O2/N2 supply panel is.
And, of course, you can just avoid that area.
Well, I should say that that area happens
to be right around the bathroom.
And so, before we repressurized the Shuttle,
the commander would say anybody who has to
use the bathroom use it now because for about
ten, fifteen minutes, while we're depressurizing,
it's off limits.
OK.
Next item.
This is the water and waste management area.
This is one of the six items.
We have potable and waste water inventory
management.
We're continually producing potable water,
as you know, and waste water.
We have to dump them, we have to use them,
so that is part of the requirement of this
system.
We have to store water for drinking, food
prep and waste water storage.
It has to be dumped to space.
Commode and urinal for human waste collection.
And we provide water for an evaporative heat
sink, which we will talk about later, called
the flash evaporator.
Yes.
This is an outstanding example of systems
engineers, this total system that Walt is
talking about.
We can really see the interaction between
all the systems and the spacecraft.
This really is a systems engineering problem.
Potable water, we take all the fuel cell byproduct
water and use it.
So it is basically in a fluent to the power
system.
We do have a launch storage capability for
water and we do provide sterilization.
The sterilization is iodine.
We started out designing a silver ion system.
It turned out that we had manufacturing problems
and the company ended up going out of business,
so we reverted to iodine.
The Lunar Module used iodine.
Waste water, the condensate from the cabin
humidity control and urine and the urine pretreat.
Urine has to be pretreated to bind the urea.
If you don't, you get a lot of ammonia.
It uses a chemical called Oxzone.
It's an acid.
I'm not really sure what it is.
This is where the system is located.
This is one of the simpler schematics.
The water tanks are here.
The water comes from the fuel cell.
As I said, by the way, the delivery is about
150 degrees and 60 psi.
So there is a lot of hydrogen dissolved in
the water.
The water is collected in the fuel cells on
the hydrogen side, so there is a lot of hydrogen.
There is a hydrogen separator here.
Otherwise, your tanks would end up full of
hydrogen which is what you don't want.
You will get water in the tanks.
The hydrogen separator is a silver palladium
metal.
It is catalyzed.
It is basically porous to hydrogen but not
to water.
If you expose the backside to the vacuum it
pulls the hydrogen off and the water goes
through just fine.
I will say that there still is a rather high
gas content in the water that you drink.
And that gas, of course, evolves once it gets
inside your stomach with predictable results.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
In fact, all sorts of systems that Jeff could
explain.
They have slinger systems and all sorts of
systems to get separation because it is not
really possible to get all the gas out of
the water.
OK.
There is a dump system.
There is a potable waste dump to vacuum.
There is also a vacuum vent, which I will
show you what that is all about.
And then the flash evaporator that I mentioned,
and I will mention more later, is in the back
of the vehicle and it has a redundant water
feed system both sides.
This is a schematic.
Start at the same place.
Water from the fuel cells goes through the
hydrogen separator and then into this bank
of tanks.
The tanks are pressurized.
They are yellow bellows tanks.
On the back side of the bellows is nitrogen.
On the forward side, of course, is the potable
water.
There is a hydrophobic filter on the downside
of each tank.
If a bellows were to leak, you don't want
water into your nitrogen system.
So this is a filter to prevent that.
I mentioned the twin flash evaporator feeds.
There they are.
This is the dump nozzle here.
The potable water system provides water to
the crew so there is a regular water interface
and a chilled water interface here.
I believe that is it.
I remember there were more problems with Apollo
than there were with Shuttle.
49:30 I don't have those sorted mentally.
I'm sorry.
I don't remember.
I'm not sure.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
Maybe that was on Apollo.
Basically that means you put your water into
a plastic bag.
And now you can actually swing it around like
so.
And so the water will go to the outside and
the gas is in the inside.
So that actually separates them and you can
squeeze the gas out through a valve.
On-orbit trash storage, there is an overboard
bleed for odor control.
It's a very small overboard bleed to vacuum.
And the human solid waste collection and storage
is also vacuum dried and stabilized.
This is a waste management picture.
The subject we were just talking about is
the vacuum vent.
That vacuum vent does vent the commode area
where the feces are.
That vent also provides a vent for the water
separator.
It also provides a vent for airlock depress
for EVA.
So this is the vacuum system.
The urine is collected and trained in a liquid.
Well, let me say that different.
The urine, after it has been separated from
the gas stream, is stored in a waste tank,
as is the humidity from the cabin atmospheric
revitalization system.
And then that is pressurized from the pressured
composition control system and is dumped overboard.
This waster is not used for anything.
It is basically dumped just to do inventory
management.
The next picture explains a little better
about the commode and the urinals themselves.
The urinal originally had a unisex interface
cup.
It turned out that didn't work very well,
and so later flights there was a custom male/female.
And later there were even some more customizing
for the crew, I believe, but I don't have
the details on that.
The urinal itself, obviously for urination,
there needs to be some way to make the urine
go where you want it to go.
And those were done in fan separators.
So there is gas pulled in the cup.
And in training the urine, the urine then
comes down and goes through the separators.
This is also a centrifugal-type separator.
And then that is sent to the head that is
created here.
Then puts that waste water urine in the waste
system.
The EMU spacesuit, it also has a condensate
drain after each EVA, and it also goes through
this same system and into the waste tank.
The commode.
Basically there is a seat.
The seat has a small opening.
The commode itself is basically a cylinder
or a tub.
And there is a slinger in the bottom.
So the slinger basically distributes the paper
and the fecal matter on the outside wall in
a thin layer.
The vacuum then can dry that so that it deactivates
it so it does not end up either any odor or
creating any kind of bacteriological issues.
But the entrainment of the fecal material
so that it, in fact, hits the slinger, is
done with an air flow.
The air flow comes in around the seat itself.
That requires good contact with the seat.
It also requires positioning.
Positioning turned out to be an early issue,
or reliable positioning, and so a trainer
was put together that had a camera here.
And the trainer, I might add, was discretely
located in a non-observable place so that
it could be used in privacy, the comings and
goings, and also the use of the facility itself.
And they told us it was not hooked up to a
tape recorder.
[LAUGHTER]
Just to elaborate on that.
Basically, the problem is it really is a rather
small opening.
And it just doesn't feel natural to know where
to put yourself down.
And it actually did lead to significant messes
on orbit.
I won't go into any more detail.
But the idea is that you would position yourself
the way you thought it should be, and then
you would turn on the lights.
And there is a TV screen in front of you.
I'm not making this up.
[LAUGHTER]
So that you could see how close you are to
the bull's-eye.
Enough said.
The cabin thermal control is another one of
the subsystem elements.
It is a circulating liquid cooling system.
It provides the heat sink for the atmosphere
itself.
It also provides the ability to reject that
heat to the spacecraft cooling system because
you've got to get rid of it out of the cabin.
It has some avionics cold plates, some air
cool avionics, support the crew in the airlock
and a portable water chiller.
This is the location.
You will notice the avionics bays are listed
here with their little circulation systems.
The liquid system then services each of those,
the chill or the condensing heat exchanger.
And this is the place that the cabin system
connects to the spacecraft system, on the
aft bulkhead right here.
We will see the other half of this system
in a little bit.
This is a schematic that is very complicated
looking but it is fairly simple.
Let me show you the air piece first.
Look at the black lines.
Those are twin fans.
It goes through the air-cooled avionics through
the heat exchanger to get rid of the heat.
There are some cold plated avionics in each
bay, so you take care of the cold plated and
the air-cooled in this bay and in this bay
and in this bay.
Now you've got all of the electronics taken
care of.
I should have started this up at the pump.
Sorry about that.
Here is the pump and we will come down.
It also takes care of the forward and overhead
window mounts around the window for thermal
control.
And the hatch is just a way to keep those
thermally stabilized.
Back in the early flights, we had something
called DFI, development flight instrumentation.
It was a special instrumentation package.
It was also liquid cooled.
And then this is the heat exchanger to the
spacecraft system.
It is a Freon system.
This is where the main heat is rejected right
here.
On the other side of this you've got cool
liquid.
It turns out this is water.
We go through the liquid cooling garment which
is the spacesuit cooling garment, the water
chiller, go through the cabin heat exchanger
to cool the cabin and condense the water out
and then back to the pump.
I failed to mention the IMU.
It has triply redundant fans.
It pulls air through it.
And that is also cooled by this gas stream.
Anyway, this is the cabin thermal control
system.
These functions, I just said each one of them
so I won't repeat them.
Cabins circulating liquid cooling loop.
As I mentioned, water is the coolant.
Water is actually a very good coolant.
And, if you have any requirements that push
you that way in your designing thermal control
systems, you like water.
Water is completely nontoxic so it can be
around the crew.
Leaks don't make any difference.
It has a very high CP.
It's a really good fluid.
The problem with water is freezing.
You don't want to freeze it and you don't
want to get it so hot that it turns into steam.
But if you can stay within the boundaries
it is a good fluid.
And that is what this is.
Redundant pumps, I showed you that on the
schematic.
The liquid gas heat exchanger, I showed you
that before.
Cold plates for electronic cooling and the
window hatch mount.
The circulating gases that I mentioned for
the avionics, the cabin gas was used as a
coolant.
You saw the redundant fans and the doubly
redundant fans.
I mentioned earlier, and someone commented
on it, that the promise early on was the Shuttle
could be a less expensive development activity
if we used off the shelf avionics, the kind
that aircraft use.
And that's a good promise.
It turned out that that's not a very good,
not as good a solution for thermal control
as liquid cooled.
Liquid cooled is a much more efficient way
of providing a heat sink to electrical equipment.
When you blow the cabin gas through it then
you end up with the problems of if you change
the pressure in the cabin, which we talked
about.
That can effect cooling.
Also you have to put out a lot more power.
You have to blow a lot more gas than you do
power to move the liquid around, so it's not
a very good thermal solution.
And actually the promise of less expensive
avionics I don't think was actually fulfilled,
although that's somebody else's topic and
not mine, because I think everything was pretty
well custom.
It did potentially complicate the thermal
control system for a good goal.
And how well that goal was met, somebody else
will have to speak for it.
Another one of the subsystem elements of the
spacecraft.
Well, we usually take a two minute break when
we're about halfway through.
Certainly.
Why don't we take our two minutes now and
then we will pick it right back up?
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
From an engineering standpoint, it is much
better to cool with liquid.
If you use cold plates, it is much more efficient.
You get a good reliable heat sink.
And you can then design your thermal conduction
paths so that out of the avionics box you
make sure the heat goes to the cold plate.
And you use a lot less power.
You can pump water a lot more efficiently
for the cooling capability than you pump gas.
Is that what happens on the Shuttle now or
do you have a mixture?
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
This is the air-cooled part of the loop and
here are the cold plates.
Let's get the class back.
Thank you very much.
I am sorry.
Did you see what I was pointing at here?
Yeah, you put both.
Yeah, and this is one bay.
And they have both cold plates and the air-cooled
here, here and here.
There they are.
Of course, when you go outside the vehicle
there is no more air so all the external equipment
is cold plated.
Was there another question?
What kind of design changes would you have
to make in order to go strictly to completely
liquid cooled electronics?
Well, if you're trying to use off-the-shelf
and it is air-cooled already, there is a cabinet
right there full of it.
If it is air-cooled already then you have
to stay with that concept.
If you're custom designing then, from the
very beginning, you say I'm custom designing
this to be liquid cooled.
And then the internal design is such that
there are conduction pads to the base plate
so that it can be cooled.
OK.
I guess previously to that all of our spacecraft
were liquid cooled.
Apollo was, wasn't it?
Yes.
Because you had to be able to take those spacecraft
down the back?
Right.
We evacuated the cabin both in the Command
Module and the Lunar Module.
And Gemini, too.
This is the spacecraft active thermal control
system.
This is the vehicle level.
So now, even though we're still under this
ETCLSS, we are not talking the classical environmental
control anymore.
This is a bigger picture.
Also the reason the word active is stuck in
here was a left over from previous programs,
too.
For example, on Apollo we had several heat
rejection systems.
Not a single one.
And we also did a lot of passive thermal control
on Apollo.
We had a mission mode called "barbeque" which
is basically you roll the vehicle very slowly
so you normalize the environment.
If you leave the same side toward the sun
all the way to the moon that side gets really
hot.
This is the active system to get away from
heaters and/or vehicle level control.
There is an on-orbit.
We have a radiative heat sink.
We also have an evaporative heat sink on orbit.
During ascent and entry we have two heat sinks,
both of which are evaporative.
We have a circulating liquid system.
We take heat from the cabin, from the fuel
cells, hydraulics, all the cold plate avionics
and electronics, and payloads, we do cooling
for payloads.
All of these are the functions of the active
thermal control system.
This, as you notice, is a lot busier than
some of the others have been.
You will notice the radiators here on the
side wall.
This is the doors.
When closed up there are no radiators.
When opened the underside of the payload doors
are your radiators.
And this is on both side, obviously.
That same heat exchanger that I showed you
before that interfaces with the cabin is right
here.
The cabin load is dumped there.
Fuel cell load is dumped here.
The fluid is a Freon 21.
There is a Freon 21 pump package.
The payload heat exchanger is here, I believe.
Mid body cold plates.
Aft cold plates.
Each radiator side has its own flow control
system.
The evaporative heat sinks, one is the flash
evaporator that I've shown you a couple times
before.
I will describe it a little better in the
minute.
It is here.
It uses water.
There is an ammonia boiler here that is also
an evaporative heat sink.
And when we're on the ground there is a GSE
connector for the GSE heat sink.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
More than you would ever know.
In fact, this is the most complicated, integrated
thermal test ever run at JSC.
And I will show you a picture of it in a minute.
We actually tested all of that together.
And it all had to work together.
And it gets worse as we go along.
I will show you all the integration factors
as we go along, but it changes from mission
mode to mission mode.
It changes within mission modes as to how
the system works.
And I will try to describe that.
OK, so this sort of gives you the feel now.
Keep in mind, geometry is going to play an
effect here as to how you plum the system
up.
So Freon is running through all of those lines
there to the radiators?
It will be a little clearer in a minute.
This is a schematic.
Let's start at the radiators.
On a good day, this is doing the job for you.
All the radiators are getting you nice cool
liquid.
The radiator uses a bypass system, so you
will see the bypass around the radiators.
It is good to remind yourselves that heat
load can be tremendously different.
And the high level mission phases, a lot of
electronics, a lot of crew activity, the vehicle
is alive and pumping out the power and, therefore,
pumping out the heat.
If you ever did one of those 28 day missions
we talked about, which was a spec requirement,
you can imagine this vehicle is almost quiescent.
It is doing very little.
You're trying to link them the mission.
So you're doing hopefully experiments or something
in SpaceLab.
You're doing something else.
The vehicle is not working for you very hard.
Just as an example, we have five computers.
And we use all five during ascent and entry,
the active phases for safety, but once you're
on orbit, when you have a long mission like
that, you actually power down all but two
of the computers.
That is just it.
And there are a lot of other systems which
you power down.
And that way you're limited in missions by
the electrical energy which is limited by
the amount of hydrogen and oxygen you can
carry for fuel cells.
So, by powering down, you extend your mission.
And, of course, you will also reduce the heat
load.
And, when you reduce the heat load, you've
got to find some way to make that same radiator
work for you at a very low heat load.
So it has the capability of getting rid of
a lot of heat.
If you don't want it to get rid of that much
heat, because you don't have it, then you
have to go to bypass system.
Anyway, the next thing in the loop is the
GSE heat exchanger.
On the ground you don't have radiators working
so you use the GSE heat exchanger.
Then there is the ammonia boiler.
When you reenter the ammonia boiler gives
you the ability to operate with an evaporative
heat sink prior to the connection of the GSE,
and so it is part of the thermal control system.
The next is the flash evaporator.
And you'll notice there are two flash chambers
here.
One is called the high load and one is called
the topper.
And I will talk about that a little more later.
Then the nice cool liquid, however it was
cooled, all these cool it.
However it was cooled is then available for
the vehicle.
And there is one more little heat load, and
that is the cryogenic oxygen that we're bringing
in.
We also warm it up with this coolant loop.
So the flow then goes to the aft cold plates.
And then the flow also goes to the cabin heat
exchanger and the payload heat exchanger.
You notice these are either or.
And that's because sometimes you don't even
have a payload heat exchanger use so you don't
use it.
Sometimes you have a lot of use for it.
And maybe, for example, SpaceLab and Space
Station have kind of an arrangement.
You wouldn't be in the cabin as much so you
can divert that.
It allows you to use the capacity in either
of two places here.
Then you come on down and come through your
pumping package, there are redundant pumps.
Then you go the fuel cell heat exchanger because
now you've used the nice cold fluid up.
And so the fuel cell can stand the warmer
temperatures.
Also some cold plates.
Now, it might have occurred to you, it occurred
to me, why did we waste our nice cold fluid
on these cold plates?
Why didn't we put those cold plates down here
so we could have had more cold fluid for our
cabin heat exchangers?
And the answer is geometry.
Those are way in the back.
The cabin is in the front.
After you've come forward from the flash evaporator,
which is in the back, to the cabin, you don't
want to go back to pick this up.
You wouldn't want to have to go back to the
back of the vehicle and then back forward
again, so this is a geometry problem.
We have cold plates here.
We also have cold plates here.
They come forward.
The hydraulics heat exchanger is the last
thing on the loop and then back to the radiators.
We will talk about that a little more.
The functions of the active thermal control
system.
Collect the waste energy from all the systems.
We just talked about that.
And rejected radiatively to space.
That is our first choice.
Our first choice is to use the radiators.
It turns out that the radiators in some heat
load environments don't do the job.
You have a high load and a bad environment,
you cannot get rid of all the heat.
Also, we are producing a lot of water, so
something constructive has to be done with
this water.
The fuel cells are pumping it out because
every time you make a kilowatt you've got
more water to use.
So we decided to augment the space radiators
with the evaporative heat sink at these high
load cases.
This gives us an ability to accept a radiator
system that cannot really do the job by itself
but make it completely adequate for some of
the low heat load cases, but in the high heat
load cases then it is augmented by water.
Now, when you want to get rid of water and
you don't have some of this bad environment
you can actually throttle the radiators down.
And, if you throttle them down, then you force
the evaporative heat sink to come online and
do the job for you.
In other words, you change the set point on
the radiator.
Normally we use 40 degrees set point.
If you change it to 56 degrees and let the
water take you from 56 back down to 40 then
you artificially get rid of water.
It is a good water dump system.
During ascent, over 100,000 feet we use the
water boiler.
The flash evaporator.
Not a water boiler.
That's a Freudian slip, I guess.
The Apollo had what's called a water boiler.
It was a nightmare.
We said never will we do that again, so we
ended up with a different design for the Shuttle.
The reentry system below 100,000 feet is ammonia.
It will carry you all the way to the ground
and on the ground until you get the GSE.
Water won't carry you because water won't
evaporate less than 100,000 feet, but the
ammonia will so that's the reason it is there.
Let's talk about the radiators themselves.
The two payload bay doors are a mirror image
of each other.
They are radiators on each side that are exactly
mirror image.
I don't know what happened there.
Anyway, this is supposed to say that the radiators
on these two sides are mounted and are plumbed
in two separate cooling loops.
The reason for that is there is always a redundant
loop.
Obviously, you have to be able to take a failure
and still have a good system.
If you run both loops through both radiator
sides and you took some sort of collision
hit then you could wipe out both of your cooling
loops in one hit.
And so that is unacceptable.
By plumbing the systems up with mirror image
radiator systems on different loops then you
can still use the capacity together.
But if you lose one side you still have half
your capacity left.
And plus you have your evaporative heat sinks
to make up the difference.
So we can survive with a door out.
I mentioned the dual set points before.
I also mentioned the bypass thermal control.
I mentioned the dual set points, 40 and 56.
40 is our normal.
If you're trying to burn up some water you
go to 56 and you use the difference in water.
The radiators, we have two different kinds
of radiators.
We have the single-sided that are on the back
of the vehicle and some two-sided ones on
the front of the vehicle.
The reason for that is when you open the door
you expose the underside of the door.
If you have radiators on the underside of
the door then you've exposed your radiators.
But if you lift the radiator panel off the
door, because the doors go way down, then
you can see the underside.
It's not as good, you don't get a full view
of the heavens, but it does get rid of heat.
And so we needed that extra capacity.
On the front four panels they are the two-sided
and on the back four they are single-sided.
The radiators themselves are made out of a
honeycomb aluminum structure.
The tubes were imbedded in the structure so
that the surface was smooth, and that was
because we wanted to use a silver Teflon tape
for our thermal control coding.
For previous vehicles we always painted the
radiators, painted them white.
If you look at the alpha epsilon white paint,
it is pretty good.
I think Apollo was 0.18 alpha and epsilon
about 0.92.
That's pretty good.
The market had moved along.
Technology had advanced and there was not
the silver Teflon out there.
And what the silver Teflon does is the silver
gives you the reflection which is good and
the Teflon gives you the radiation which is
good, so you get the best of both worlds.
Silver Teflon was about 0.05 epsilon and about
0.88, 0.9, something like that.
You lost a slight amount in epsilon and gained
a lot in alpha, so basically you could ignore
the sun which is what you'd like to do, is
ignore the sun.
It turned out the silver Teflon had some issues.
We tested the radiators.
The radiator was not a slam dunk with eight
panels, four of which are two-sided.
Effectively you have 12 panels.
You have fluid going through those in parallel
tubes.
You're trying to guaranty that the fluid all
goes where it's supposed to go.
And, therefore, the viscosity of Freon, which
is very low, analytically said it was all
right.
But we wanted some testing to prove it so
we did test the entire radiator system.
And, in that test, all the silver Teflon fell
off.
It is a really good thermal coating but it
doesn't seem to be very practical.
It turned out that the problem was adhesive.
We did a little adhesive work and the materials
people came up with a Permacel that worked
perfectly.
They have never come off again.
In fact, we get 10, 12 years out of the radiators,
lots of time.
The problem that the Permacel couldn't solve
was beneath the tape you could get very small
little out-gassing of the materials.
Almost all materials outgas some.
Basically, we would put bubbles underneath
the tape.
We went to a perforated.
There are millions of little holes in this
tape.
And it is placed on the vehicle and it stayed
on just fine.
It wasn't very long, though, that people began
to worry about the focusing of this silver,
that the doors are curved upward.
And so there is a focal point there that is
a very, very hot point.
And there was concern that that's really not
a good thing to have.
If we could make the surface less specular
and more diffuse without losing the alpha
and epsilon we would have a better design.
And so they dimpled it.
Now we have Permacel dimpled, perforated silver
Teflon tape.
It works great.
The flash evaporator.
Water is the flash evaporator's evaporant.
This was a brand-new design.
The water boiler on Apollo was no good.
It was a problem.
The flash evaporator is a very simple concept.
You have a chamber.
You run your coolant around the chamber that
you want to be cooled.
And you spray water on the walls of the chamber.
And, if the pressures are all right, the water
will flash.
You won't get ice.
It will go straight to steam.
Steam will go overboard and it will all be
wonderful.
And if you can convince a program manager
of that good luck.
Anyway, the way to convince a program manager
is to show him good test data.
During the development, we developed this
process of spraying the walls and not getting
water carryover which will obviously freeze
up your steam duct.
Which you don't want.
But, as the design evolved, we had to get
more sophisticated because we needed this
flash evaporator to burn up the extra water
when we didn't need the fuel cell water.
And we did that with that 40 to 56 set point.
And so we needed a small evaporator that could
handle that.
It was called the "topper." It tops off the
radiator.
But when the doors are closed there is nothing
else to get rid of your heat, now you need
a loss of capacity.
And so the second chamber was the hallowed
chamber.
Together they do the whole job.
When the radiators are working only topper,
you can come home with this system functional
and make it home.
It turns out we never did freeze up the steam
duct so that part was good.
It turns out that we had some freezing in
the chamber.
And, in fact, we had to develop a process
that acknowledged that that could occur.
And how would we flush it?
It is called "flushing." And so we did develop
a process.
And it has never failed.
The flushing process always works.
And we have had on several occasions, I probably
cannot count them for you, but four of five
times maybe over the Shuttle flights we've
had some freezing inside the cavities.
There is a non-propulsive overboard vent.
That was the one going out both sides for
the topper because it could be used for very
long times during the mission and you might
be pointing or whatever you might be doing.
But when you're coming home the high load
is just a big out the side of the vehicle
type duct.
The ammonia boiler, its heat sink is ammonia.
As I mentioned before, it evaporates all the
way to the ground where the water won't.
The redundant boiler is here.
Up here there are no redundant boilers.
These two chambers have redundant everything.
They have redundant feed water systems and
redundant control systems, redundant spray
nozzles, redundant everything, but the chamber
is a chamber.
You get what you get.
They are redundant boilers is the way the
ammonia boiler gets its redundancy.
It was designed to be utilized during entry
and on the runway until the cooling is available.
It turns out that we don't do that anymore.
It turns out operationally we learned that
if we cold soak the radiators before we shut
the doors and then bypass them and come home
on the flash evaporator that there is a lot
of heat capacity still left in those radiators.
There is a lot of fluid out there and it is
cold.
And so we can actually go all the way to wheel
stop on the radiator.
And so at 175,000 feet we start flowing the
radiator.
And at 100,000 feet the flash evaporator is
off and we cold soak all the way home.
And after wheel stop the ammonia boiler cranks
up.
I mentioned the Freon 21, the low viscosity.
We got an excellent performance out of that.
The low viscosity is really, really important,
as much parallelism as we have.
I didn't really give you the numbers.
In the single panels we have 26 tubes.
In the two-sided panels, I believe, there
are 66 tubes.
Lots of tubes.
Lots of parallelism.
It is awfully easy to get flow instability
in a thermal system like that but the Freon
loop does great.
We have redundant pumps, all liquid heat exchangers
and cold plates.
This is that chamber that I told you.
If you can look right down here, this is one
person.
In fact, there is a radiator panel.
This was during buildup.
Twice we tested the flash evaporator in this
environment once as part of the integrated
system with all the radiators and once by
itself.
And twice we tested the radiators, one as
part of the integrated system and once by
themselves.
So we did essentially three large tests.
And the one that had the entire system in
it, had all the cold plates, had everything
in it, as I said, is the most sophisticated
thermal test we've ever done at JSC.
And it proved that the system could work.
It also proved that we had to tune the flash
evaporator nozzle because it was wrong.
But we did get the data, we did prove it was
wrong and we got it re-machined.
A machine out of columbium, somebody else
will have to answer why.
And so it was a problem for Aaron to go get
us another one, but it fixed it and it was
successful.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
You can have a command module and a service
module and a stack configuration in side that
chamber.
And it had a solar and full vacuum.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
It was a manned chamber then.
It is not now.
After Apollo-Soyuz, it hasn't been manned
since then.
It's still available for testing but is not
manned.
It has a sister chamber 100 feet that way
where all of the EVA testing is done.
A good example, I think, of how the Shuttle
Program built on a lot of Apollo-- The same
thing at the Cape where a lot of the launch
hardware was adapted is the Shuttle Program,
you know, you heard about the budgetary constraints.
The Shuttle Program never could have afforded
to build something like that.
But luckily a lot of this equipment was built
during Apollo when the money was much more
available.
If you have been keeping count, we're getting
toward the end here.
I did want to mention, before we left the
main orbiter systems, that there was some
rotating equipment life testing that we did
for the program.
The equipment we're talking about here is
the cabin fan, the water gas separators, the
avionics bay fans, cabin coolant and the vehicle
coolant pumps.
The life requirement was 100 missions, and
that was calculated by somebody to be 20,000
hours.
If you could show 20,000 hours of successful
operation, you had the design life of the
hardware.
We set up a laboratory to run the equipment.
It was obviously a low-maintenance lab.
We collected data and checked in the room
occasionally to see if everything was all
right.
It turned out that all the equipment passed
the 20,000 hour requirement.
We did learn something, though, that some
of that stuff was so noisy.
Oh, it was noisy.
There was some work done on some muffling,
but the hardware itself was all good.
We are at the end.
Yes.
Were there noise requirements [AUDIENCE QUESTION]?
Yes, there was a cabin noise spec.
And, yes, it had to be met.
And I don't remember how it was met.
We put mufflers on some of the equipment.
Maybe some insulation inside of the ducting,
I'm not sure.
If we have time, COHEN: I will tell a little
anecdote here.
I chaired the Change Control Board.
[NOISE OBSCURES]
The medical organization came to see me and
said that the cabin was very, very noisy and
it was going to really do a detriment to the
astronauts.
And it was very expensive in terms of dollars
and weight to really get all the cabin fans
and cabin environment down to the level they
wanted.
I thought for a moment.
I go out to California a lot.
I go out to Rockwell and stay in motels that
are on the Los Angeles freeway.
And I said you don't see me worried about
my ears in staying in those freeways and not
being able to sleep and having all that noise.
And the doctor looked at me for a moment and
said, well, you're already deaf.
And I said what did you say?
But we did have to make some modifications
of it to actually reduce noise.
Let me interject one item.
I think somebody asked the issue about the
IMU.
We decided to pick the IMU off the shelves,
and it was air-cooled, to really do it right.
If we would have done it right, we would have
picked an IMU which was compatible with liquid
cooling rather than redesign it.
But we decided to stick with the IMU that
was air-cooled.
Whether that was the right decision to make,
I don't know.
It seemed like it was because I think we've
only had one problem with an IMU.
I don't think we've had many problems with
the IMU.
But that is a little anecdote that I thought
of.
That's a program manager's trait.
Probably the air-cooled IMU was a less expensive
option.
It might have cost a little in terms of thermal
efficiency, but that is only energy power.
And power was available so it was a good tradeoff.
This is the last of the subsystem areas.
This is the EVA airlock support.
The Environmental Thermal Control and Life
Support System does support the airlock.
It maintains the cabin pressure and composition
during the airlock repress and depress.
This is really a requirement back on the ARS
and the pressure and composition control system
because airlock use basically dumps cabin
gas and then you repress the airlock.
It is a requirement that you cannot upset
the cabin while you're doing the EVA function.
We also provide the service and cooling umbilical.
If you have any kind of mental picture of
being in the airlock, the crew is connected
with cooling and oxygen through an umbilical
so they don't use the consumables in their
spacesuit.
And so that is provided by the ETCLSS.
Heat rejection, the crew wears a liquid cooling
garment.
And the cooling for that is done by the vehicle
until you go EVA, of course.
Then the recharge.
We supply the backpack O2 recharge from the
900 PSI cryo.
We supply the water to recharge for the sublimator.
NASA is overrun with acronyms.
EMU is extra vehicular mobility unit, which
means nothing but spacesuit and backpack.
So the spacesuit and backpack uses an evaporative
heat sink and it uses a sublimator.
And the idea there is it's a device that exposes
a layer of ice to space and then it sublimates
and you get your cooling from that as opposed
to putting a liquid water on a surface and
flashing it.
Anyway, that has to be serviced.
That water is provided from the system.
And then the condensate that the crew brings
back, EVA, that's a sweaty job.
That condensate goes back into the system.
So the airlock support is another part of
this system.
In fact, that is the sixth part.
So we are through.
This is a picture of the airlock.
Not really the airlock.
This is the test chamber that we built to
put the equipment in.
You'll notice it has the right hatch in it.
And, if you can recall back an hour and a
half ago, I showed you a picture where there
was this hatch basically on the backside of
the test chamber.
We hook those together.
Because, as I said, as you depress and repress
the airlock it affects the cabin.
So we needed a test environment that had both
those simultaneously.
But the difference is this has to go all the
way to vacuum.
So we connected this to our vacuum system.
And, when the crew is inside this, it is a
manned vacuum test.
And when the crew is inside the other test
chamber it is basically sea level or, at most,
8 PSI would be the lowest it would ever be.
And I think the last picture is a spacesuit
inside the airlock.
And this is just a little cutaway showing
the airlock.
This was mounted on the back of that chamber
you saw earlier.
If you bring that picture back up, I will
talk to that for just a minute and then we
will have some questions.
Before every flight, one of the things that
we do is that every EVA crewmember takes his
or her spacesuit into that EVA test chamber,
into the airlock test chamber so you actually
get a chance to take your own suit down to
vacuum.
And particularly, before you do your very
first EVA, it is really a confidence builder
because the physical sensations that you get
in a suit -- And remember you're at about
a 4 PSI pure oxygen environment.
Your body, the inside of your mouth feels
a little different.
There are funny sounds with the fans inside
the suit.
The sorts of things that you don't want to
experience the first time when you actually
go outside into space.
It is much better to do it here in a controlled
environment where if there is a problem -- Actually,
you are supported because of the weight of
the suit.
It doesn't look like there is anybody in this
suit.
But, when you're in this suit, you're actually
supported by a cable to the ceiling of the
chamber which is on quick release bolts.
You're suspended up here.
And, if you ever have a problem, they can
release this, repressurize the chamber within
about 30 seconds.
I think that's the limit for a manned rated
chamber.
You're going to be able to repress in about
30 seconds and then just lift you out, suit
and all from the top, and get you out of your
suit and get you to the medics.
This is just an inverted bell jar.
The hatch is not sealed.
When you depress it just like pulls it out
and seals due to the pressure difference.
You just lift the top off.
Yet another example of the extensive testing
that we go through before every mission.
I might add one more thing, which I forgot
actually to add earlier.
The manned rating is a term used in manned
spacecraft which means that you've specifically
tested it and said that its design is worthy
of supporting a human.
The airlock had to provide that function.
So Aaron was faced with man rating the airlock.
And manned test capability is very scarce.
In fact, JSC may be the only place anymore
that can do it.
Anyway, we volunteered to do that as part
of our test program as a programmatic requirement.
Not as testing or watching or confirming anything,
but as a prime part of the test program was
the manned rating of the airlock.
And that was done in Houston.
That is an interesting thought.
If my memory serves me correctly, one of the
problems we had in the early part of the Manned
Space Program was doing some chamber runs
McDonnell-Douglas with a two-gas system where
we actually lost the heat [NOISE OBSCURES]
in the chamber and almost lost a test subject.
And that was when Apollo decided to go to
100% oxygen.
And that is what led up to the fire on the
pad.
It went to 100% oxygen at 16 pounds per square
inch with an invert over the hatch for another
reason.
And that is really if you can realize that
100% oxygen at 16 PSI everything burns.
Stainless steel is not self-extinguishing
at 16 PSI.
And, of course, that's what we were up when
we had the Apollo I fire on the pad.
It was a function of doing some test work
with the combined atmosphere.
So you have got to be careful that sometimes
you don't over-react the thing.
Then we went back to a different type of atmosphere.
Did you have a question?
The systems you've been describing today seem
to take up a lot of space in the Orbiter like
other systems.
How did you negotiate and manage other subsystems
for the space and the volume in the way that
you wanted?
That is a good question but you're asking
the wrong person.
We are the government.
We hired a contractor to design the vehicle.
Now, the design aspects of it, the philosophy
of it, the functionality of it we were very,
very integral with.
We watched, we audited, we said that looks
smart, but we didn't go and say put that cold
plate here and put that heat exchanger there.
The vehicle integrated design was Rockwell's.
Let me tell you how it was done.
Actually, in those years we didn't have CAD/CAM
systems.
What we did is used everything on mockups.
We did mockups.
The system was laid out of what to do and
the functions of what they had to do and the
plumbing.
And this was all laid out on a mockup.
And basically that was how it was negotiated
in terms of what you need.
In today's environment you wouldn't do that.
You would use electronic capability.
You would use your CAD/CAM systems.
You would actually draw it up on your computer.
In fact, the 777 was built that way.
The 777 at Boeing, they didn't use hard mockups.
They used electronic mockups.
And that is what we would do today.
And it would be much easier.
You would probably call all the engineers
together.
You would sit down and show how the equipment
was laid out, get a satisfactory buyoff on
it and do it much more rapidly and much more
quickly.
In the future, what you will be doing is actually
use a CAD/CAM system or CAD system to actually
negotiate the space you need for it.
That is a good question.
And it was based on purely that you would
get drawings, mockups, go out and lay it out
in a soft mockup or hard mockup.
You would get the engineers to come out, the
manufacturing people to come out and say this
is how it is going to look and then get a
buyoff on it.
Today you wouldn't do it that way.
You would do it all electronically so it would
change.
Well, let me ask you a question.
Of all the work you've done in the Shuttle
what was your biggest concern in getting ready
to fly or during the flight?
What did you have the biggest concern about?
I was young and confident.
I don't know that I had a specific area that
I was really concerned about.
Like these people right here, right?
Young and confident.
I did recognize, though, but it did result
in the integrated tests that I showed.
I did recognize that we had the most highly
integrated thermal control system ever conceived.
And it had, as I said, modes within modes.
It changed modes with respect to the vehicle
phases.
It changed modes with respect to operation.
We had 9 PSI that went to 10.2 PSI.
We had 8 PSI.
We had thermal control loops, ammonia boilers,
flash evaporators, so I did recognize the
sophistication.
In fact, we proposed early on to use that
large chamber in an integrated vehicle test.
Not we, me, but the big we looked at an integrated
test like the Command Service Module was tested.
And that was viewed to be impractical.
It was cut it off at the bulkhead.
You could do the forward cabin part and then
do the aft section, but that was viewed to
be impractical.
But it still was a very integrated design.
All the systems engineering that was there
created that inner-dependency.
And I think I was smart enough to know that
there was certainly some potential risks there.
Remember in the very beginning of this I talked
about ownership of all the technical aspects?
We had ownership.
We believed that what we had done was prudent,
appropriate, and we believed it would work.
It wasn't like you bought something and you
hope it works.
Can you say a word of what you think, this
is looking in your crystal ball, about the
CEV?
Do you think it's going to have a very similar
type system or have you thought about that?
Well, we hope so.
Our new administrator has sort of back to
the grassroots philosophy, or at least right
now.
And so we hope that the CEV will be developed
with a lot of government involvement, that
the government will have ownership again of
the technical aspects of the design.
If that happens then I think a lot of the
experience that is around and a lot of the
free-thinking and the independence that the
government can bring to that, there is another
school of thought that says keep the government
out of the way and let the contractor go do
their thing.
And, obviously, you wouldn't get that position
from me but there are people that believe
that's the right way to do it.
Do you think the system will look pretty much
like this or similar to it?
Well, similar, yes, I do think so.
I believe that the very tight schedule for
the CEV is going to put a lot of pressure
on the program manager to go with the tried
and true.
So I don't think there is going to be innovation
that has risk with it.
Maybe there will be innovation that is good
engineering, but I think the innovation with
risk will be very much minimized.
Because taking Shuttle offline in 2010 there
is going be a lot of pressure to get this
vehicle finished.
I think that is going to breed some conservatism
on the design side.
We talk about considering operation while
you're doing the design, but there were always
things once the design was made.
Well, like you mention, once we came up with
a requirement for a 10.2 cabin we had to develop
workarounds.
And one of the other things that after the
system is designed, we then start to figure
out how can it fail and work on malfunction
procedures.
And I know that the malfunction procedure
for loss of two coolant loops that was probably
the worst simulation case that we ever had
to deal with.
I am curious to get your opinion.
Walt described how we have two independent
cooling loops so that in principle one failure
won't take them both out.
Now, I don't remember what it was, but they
did discover a single point failure somewhere
in there which I think was corrected but where
you could have lost both of the cooling loops
with a single failure.
The only failure I remember is one that John
Young used to worry about.
It had to do with if you did lose a radiator
that that could bleed your accumulator down.
And so they did add an isolation valve so
they can isolate the radiator side.
But the idea was to obviously not lose your
fluid with a single hit.
That even though you have a nice completely
functional thermal control system it is useless
because it has no fluid.
We did have an emergency de-orbit procedure
for loss of two Freon cooling loops.
And, of all the things that we practices,
that was the hairiest because it was absolutely
time critical.
At this point, you have no way of getting
heat out of the cabin so you cannot ultimately
cool your electronics.
The cabin gets hot, your electronics get hot
so you have to do an immediate de-orbit.
Hopefully you're within range of a landing
site.
And then you turn off all the equipment that
you can possibly turn off, including most
of your computers.
And, when you're riding down through entry,
you basically watch the temperature of the
computer.
And, as each computer would get up to its
failure temperature, you would then switch
on the next computer, transfer the data, you
know, turn off the computer which has just
about failed, and hopefully you could make
it to the ground.
And I know the instructors that would lead
us through this exercise said that the information
they had gotten from the thermal analyst was
that nobody was really sure whether we could
make it.
I don't know what your opinion was or not.
We practiced it.
But obviously, I think I've told you, nobody
has ever died in a simulator.
But you never know whether the thermal model
that they use in the simulator is really going
to duplicate the way the Shuttle is going
to behave in an absolute emergency situation
like that.
We survived in the simulator but I don't know
what your feeling is.
Well, we do address the thermal model accuracy.
We do specific testing to validate the thermal
model so we do have pretty good confidence
in those.
But the real issue in overheat is that when
does a piece of equipment stop working in
an overheat situation?
I mean there is no magic number.
It is not like at 143 degrees it is OK and
144 it is not OK.
And it varies with age, it varies with equipment
and it varies with a lot of things.
So there wasn't really a precise answer as
to how long you could keep everything functional
and come home.
Yes.
You talked earlier a little about oxygen and
nitrogen mixing in the cabin.
I was wondering if there is a way to really
study that on the ground since you're not
in a DoD environment.
How do you know there are not pockets of nitrogen
sitting around that an astronaut can stick
his heat into?
Very good.
I just forgot to mention that earlier.
The testing that we ran, we had to set it
up very carefully.
If you notice, there is a flight deck and
a mid-deck, so obviously buoyancy is going
to mix that stuff for you.
What we did is set up a thermal condition
where less than one degree thermal gradient
everywhere in there had to exist before we
ran the test.
And that was to guaranty that we had no help
from the naturally induced circulation.
But you are absolutely right.
That test would have been a useless test without
neutralizing the gravity effects.
And actually the first time that I did the
spacesuit test in there we actually used the
10.2 protocol.
So I actually had to go in the day before,
take the cabin to 10.2, spend the night and
then we could do just a 40 minute prebreathe.
For most of the other tests, when you go in,
in order to avoid the inconvenience and expense
of staying through the night, you go in early
in the morning.
And then you're coming right from a sea level
environment.
So, before you go down to 4 PSI in the suit,
you actually have to prebreathe pure oxygen
for four hours.
As Walt said, that was the alternative.
You basically just get in your suit.
You can either bring a book and read your
book or they will pipe music into you if you
want to give them a CD, or I guess there was
an audiocassette in those days, or they have
a little black and white TV monitor.
And you just sort of sit there for four hours.
And the problem is you're not allowed to go
to sleep.
That would be the easiest thing, but they
want you actually to move around because when
you're moving your muscles you're actually
then doing a better job of de-nitrogenating.
So you have to stay awake.
And if you don't say anything for more than
about 10 minutes they will pipe something
in and say, Jeff, are you awake?
But this was a very, very useful facility.
I mean they used it for all different sorts
of things.
And I guess that was the one new facility
which was built for the Shuttle specifically.
Yes.
Jeff mentioned several times the 10.2 and
I talked about the 9.
The 9 was the original design, but the issues
with the 9 PSI had to do with the oxygen percentage
got too high.
And so there was much concern about flammability.
The idea was if you could raise the pressure
up some to 10.2 then that would be less of
a flammability issue.
But then the problem became at 10.2 that the
suit at 4 PSI was too much of a drop.
If you're in the bends while diving, somebody
mentioned diving earlier, scuba, you could
usually use a two to one.
If you don't reduce pressure more than half
you're probably OK.
You're probably not going to get the bends,
but half of 10.2 is not 4.
And the suit is at 4, so there was that issue
again.
They raised and bumped the suit up a little
bit and got it up to 4.3 and went to 10.2
and developed the prebreathe protocols that
made that acceptable.
That is sort of how it balanced out.
That was another operational move later.
And, as Walt said, you're spending enough
time, once you get in the suit and you purge
all the nitrogen out, and so you're sitting
in a pure oxygen environment, you've got to
do a bunch of tests and check out communication
tests and cooling tests.
You basically are not losing much time by
having to spend 40 minutes prebreathing.
The whole thing worked out pretty well.
And it will be an interesting question on
how they designed the CEV because the CEV
has to be compatible with docking to the Space
Station which works at a sea level environment.
But, on the other hand, if you're going to
take the CEV into a situation where you want
to do a lot of space walks, you probably want
to be able to operate it at more like 8.5
or 9 PSI so that you can go right into a spacesuit
without an extensive prebreathe.
And, of course, people are always trying to
figure out could we design the spacesuit to
work at a higher pressure?
But then you give up maneuverability.
We will talk about that in another lecture
that I will be giving on EVA systems.
Walt, thank you very much.
I enjoyed it.
[APPLAUSE]